HEALTH DIRECTOR DR. FRANCIS
COLLINS IN JUST A MOMENT.
WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE.
PETER DOOCY IS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WITH NEW INFORMATION ON
THE USE OF BOOSTER SHOTS FROM
THE MOST VULNERABLE AMERICANS.
FIRST THE STATE DEPARTMENT
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON IN WHAT
SOME SAY WAS THE TRUE GENESIS OF
THE CORONAVIRUS.
GOOD EVENING, RICH.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
A WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
EXPERT TELLS DANISH TELEVISION
IT IS PROBABLE A RESEARCHER IN A
WUHAN LAB WORKING WITH BATS MAY
HAVE BEEN THE FIRST HUMAN
INFECTED WITH COVID-19.
THIS IS SCIENTIST PETER BRETHREN
EMIRATE.
HE SAYS IS HE PART OF A
DOCUMENTARY ON DANISH TELEVISION
AIRING TONIGHT WHERE HE CLAIMS
HE HAD CONCERNS ABOUT SAFETY
CONCERNS ABOUT A LAB IN WUHAN
AND CHINESE GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
PRESSURED THE W.H.O. TO DROP ANY
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
POSSIBILITY THE VIRUS BEGAN IN A
LAB.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, THE W.H.O.
TEAM RELEASED A REPORT CLAIMING
A LAB LEAK WAS EXTREMELY
UNLIKELY.
BEN ELM BRING NOW NOTICE IN THAT
SCIENTISTS DENIED ACCESS TO LAB
BOOKS AND DOCUMENTS.
THE W.H.O. TEAM ONLY RECEIVED
PRESENTATION.
THERE IS NO DIRECT EVIDENCE THAT
THE OUTBREAK IS RELATED TO THE
RESEARCH CONDUCTED AT WUHAN'S
LABS.
JUST THIS AFTERNOON THE W.H.O.
RELEASED A STATEMENT CALLING ON,
QUOTE:  ALL GOVERNMENTS TO
DEPOLITICIZE THE SITUATION AND
COOPERATE TO ACCELERATE THE
ORIGIN'S STUDIES.
THAT INCLUDES A POTENTIAL LAB
LEAK.
CHINA HAS CRITICIZED ANY
SUGGESTION THAT COVID-19 BEGAN
IN A LAB AND HAS INSTEAD
DEMANDED THE W.H.O. INVESTIGATE
U.S. BIOLABS.
ONE STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WHO INVESTIGATE YOU HAD THE
ORIGINS OF THE VIRUS UNDER THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION, CLAIMS
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT IS
COVERING UP THE LAB LEAK.
>> THE CHINESE CESSPOOL OF LIES
THEY HAVE BEEN PROPAGATING FROM
DAY ONE ON THIS THING, WHEN, YOU
KNOW, RATHER THAN LOOKING FOR A
VIRUS AND ITS ORIGINS THEY SEEM
TO KNOW WHERE IT CAME FROM FROM
DAY ONE AND THEY START
PROPAGATING A COVER STORY.
>> EARLIER THIS MONTH,
REPUBLICAN OPS THE HOUSE FOREIGN
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE RELEASED A
REPORT CLAIMING THE
PREPONDERANCE OF THE EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THE VIRUS WAS
ACCIDENTALLY RELEASED FROM A
WUHAN LAB.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
INITIATED AN INTELLIGENCE REVIEW
INTO THE ORIGINS OF THE
PANDEMIC.
THAT REPORT IS DUE THE WEEK
AFTER NEX